Some groups just don't get along everyday.
Billions of soldiers fight a merciless war on thousands of fronts.
And it's been going on for over 100 million years.
The world war.
Are ancient beings that arose around 160 million years ago and took over a
wide variety of ecological niches.
So successfully that they became one of the dominant animals on planet earth.
Today, they count more than 16,000 different species with over 10,000
trillion individuals,
collectively ants alone make up 20% of the entire animal
biomass on land. Similar to humans.
Their recipe for success is collaboration.
While a single plant is pretty useless together,
they are able to achieve stunning feats.
They construct complex colonies care for livestock, pursue agriculture,
or have complex symbiotic relationships. And of course,
and wage war, even among the same species,
a constant state of conflict is pretty common. Skirmishes,
raids and full on invasions are happening every day,
causing millions of casualties.
Let's look at some of the most interesting ones in a series of videos in
this one, the army and a swarm made for war.
The army and group consists of about 200 different species.
Army ants do not build nests.
They live a sort of nomadic lifestyle with groups of millions of individuals on
a hunt, some species for large columns, up to 100 meters,
long killing and immediately dismembering every insect or small vertebra they
encounter.
The biggest hunting part is can kill up to 500,000 animals per day.
Some army ants specialize in hunting and consuming other social insects
like termites wasps,
and especially other ads wasps our fears and may seem
invulnerable. But if a swamp makes its way to their colonies,
they don't even stand a chance.
The much bigger and stronger wasps might kill a few of them,
but they are quickly overwhelmed.
Even if they're queen survives that attack the army ants steal the colonies
larvae and quickly devoured them. There is no recovery from that.
When army ants discover another and colony, they immediately attack.
Now you might think this would be a more even battle,
but it's not because army ants act as a social unit.
They are especially dangerous and defective.
Most army ants are not particularly impressive individually,
but they can overwhelm their victims with sheer before the victim colony can
mountain effective defense.
And so invasions tend to be won by the attackers and the prey colony is damaged
significantly or is exterminated.
Interestingly army ants don't fight army ants. When two swarms in country,
each other in the wild, they either pass through each other,
ignoring the other swarm or both colonies just move away.
Which makes sense from an evolutionary standpoint,
army ants that fought other army ants probably eradicated themselves millions of
years ago. Indeed.
They're so deadly that other ant species had to specialize to survive their
presence. Many species, just panic and evacuate their nest.
When they notice army and Scouts carrying as many larvae with them as they can
in order to return and rebuild. After the attack,
other species have invented living bunkers since fighting is so futile.
They have worker classes that have big square heads. When army ants show up,
they use them to block the entrances to their nests.
So the attackers have to give up after a while,
but not everybody is afraid of army ants,
leaf cutter ants form some of the largest and most complex societies of any
animal. Other than humans. They live in extensiveness,
many meters deep and across harboring millions of citizens with a highly
sophisticated division of labor, like huge soldiers,
100 times more massive than a worker,
their sole purpose might be to defend their colonies against army ads.
They still have a nemesis though. The diet of the army and species,
no murmur mix. As in Becky,
I consists mostly of the larvae of the other ants compared to other army ants.
They have a more robust soldier cast so far.
They are the only known species that can successfully attack a mature colony of
leaf cutters. When they find a leaf cutter colony,
hundreds of thousands attack in a long column,
the moment the leaf cutter ants notice the army and attack.
They go into crisis mode and immediately alert their soldiers who very quickly
swarmed the site of attack.
A frontline develops that can be a few meters wide and up to a meter deep,
the leaf cutter soldiers go head to head with the army and look in on them and
try to cut through their heads.
Smaller leaf cutter workers help by grabbing the enemies.
Small teams carry out attacks behind the frontline,
where they dismember there and amazed by ripping their legs from their bodies.
The attackers, meanwhile,
try to swarm their victim soldiers and sting them to death in a mob,
despite the powerful defense and the determined response,
the army ants are still superior in numbers.
So without knowing if the battle can be won,
the leaf cutters prepare for the worst workers rushed to create barricades and
seal off as many entrances to their nest as possible to secure their brood.
If the leaf cutters are not able to repel the invaders or at least barricade
enough of their entrances in time,
the army ants swarm and asked overrunning all opposition,
they penetrate deep into the hidden chambers and steal tens of thousands of the
leaf cutters brew to eat them. Even if the leaf cutter colony survives,
this is a heavy blow regardless who's won the war
thousands,
lay slain on the battlefields when the army ants attack death follows
them, but there are other species that form much more dangerous.
And Thomas species that form super colonies covering thousands of square
kilometers over multiple continents,
engaging in Wars kilometers across they deserve their own video though.
No matter the scale war is a part of ant existence.
Be it between huge colonies or small groups trying to fend off a rate
in tropical rainforests, but also in the cracks of the concrete.
We walk over every day.
Humans have decided that war is not a thing that they want to do a lot anymore
for ants though. The other end will always be the enemy.
Some groups just don't get along.
If you can't get enough events where developing part two of the answer is right
now with the support of curiosity stream,
curiosity stream is a subscription streaming service with thousands of
documentaries and nonfiction titles coats,
cause out viewers can visit curiositystream.com/ [inaudible] to get a free 31
day trial to watch films like big world in a small garden.
The documentary that takes a close look at the world of insects around us or
other documentaries by the likes of Stephen Hawking, David Attenborough,
and many more all available for offline viewing.
Once your trial is over the subscription is only $2 and 99 cents per month.
CuriosityStream was founded by the same people who started the discovery channel
with documentary spanning science, nature, history, technology, and lifestyle.
It's a great way to binge watch fun videos while accidentally learning things.
Thank you so much to our friends at curiosity stream for supporting our aunts
obsession and making ambitious projects like this possible.
Stay tuned for part two and visit curiosity stream.com/ [inaudible] for
your free trial.